You're okay, I'll test this side you're here, then I'll test this side, you're okay, you're okay, it's okay.
I'll just need to test the audio level, so why?
That's all I need to do, shh, it's okay, it's okay.
I had to test the audio level Starlet Noray, it's okay.
You can fit the brush and I'll read them all, boy.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
We're taking it nice and steady, and you may notice that there's a new emote for those of you who have emotes.
It turns out that I had so many gifted memberships, but I lost the cream, not being a GR, so there may not be a pregnant me at the moment temporarily.
It's not gonna stay, but just so you know, it's there.
Thank you to everyone who has gifted membership or become a member.
I do, I have a long-term emote slot because of that, and thank you for everyone.
Hey, check the pregnant with you ASMR, people will know it's a volume low, is it too low?
Hold on, I can do this, okay, I'm just turning myself up.
I can also turn myself on.
Mommy has a cup of tea, so I'm gonna have some tea, okay?
Do you want the volume up louder?
I can better up a wee bit louder as well.
You do.
Yeah, I think people were like, oh, this meme, this ASMR is obviously going to be a meme.
And then, surprise, it's actually the most try-hard ASMR I've probably done so far.
Okay, I'm gonna drink my tea, my honey tea.
I have an update for Patreon, so because of a very small oversight, I apologize to snippets,
but everyone now has their four months Patreon up, but that was just a few internal issues.
For my Reflings on Patreon, I have wrote the script of I Groom You.
I will be recording it very shortly, and it will go up today, because I need a little day.
The viewer clipping program is also about to launch, and I am a very tired little cut offish.
I've had three hours of sleep, oh dear, oh dear, oh dear, oh dear, oh dear, oh dear.
I'm gonna just, okay, I'm gonna slurp my cup of tea, okay?
But oh dear, oh dear, oh dear, yes, three hours.
Three hours is not enough, no, I don't think it is either.
I don't think it is either.
Thank you for the pregnancy ASMR you did great.
I had so many nice comments.
A lot of people said, like, oh, it looks like a shitpost, but when you click on it, it sprawls up,
and I'm like, yeah, that's a surprise.
You think it's gonna be low quality, and no surprise.
Being pregnant with 9000 of us.
Mommy Kate's treasure is what she cannot be said.
Well, someone was like, oh, I was hoping the next day were in you,
he'll be in your stomach, and I'm like, oh, so you want me to go back to the artist
and get a three part four artwork?
Say no more.
Don't think I won't go back to the artist and draw me eating you and thank you in my stomach.
And I'll get the cry in the mouth of you in my stomach.
So thank you for becoming a member, I appreciate it.
I'm not gonna role play this stream, okay?
I didn't prepare anything to role play, so I'm gonna tinkle you,
and I'm gonna give you kisses all through this stream, deal?
Deal.
What does it mean?
No, no, no.
It's a role play.
I'll make a role play of me eating you.
Yeah, so we will be having fun with that very shortly.
I'm down now.
We win as every other day.
And things are moving so fast, I'm not even kidding.
Now it's not a four stream, relax.
I'm not eating you, okay?
I'm not eating you.
I'm seeing my next cursed ASMR on YouTube, like as a video, not a stream.
And as I'm gonna eat you.
I mean, come on, look at my teeth.
My first thesis for sleep deprived mommy.
I think I may just put you in my tummy for a little bit and then I'll
spend you back up again, because I don't want you to be obscenity spaghetti.
I don't like when you perish in the ASMR full place, it makes me sad.
So I think I'll just let you sleep in my stomach and then I'll bring you home,
or I'm gonna imply I'll bring you home, okay?
Disgustingly, I cure barf.
Okay, I finished my day.
As always, I have my little blue, blue, blue.
Blue, blue, blue.
Protect us from the stomach acid, mummy fruit.
Actually, the teeth you have are too bright for me.
And you do for, you have to do something with a pelican knife.
For informants, really, it's real hard.
Clearly, it's pretty cool to the brain that it's ASMR.
The artist did such a good job, honestly.
So we're being avoided.
Yeah, I'm not putting any digestion stuff on yet.
I don't want you to perish at the role play.
I love you replaying some of the best for you.
And if you get digested, then that's not the best.
Next.
Wow.
No, no.
These ones are elite.
See, when the last one goes like, click on the glass,
I don't like when it does that though.
That's bad ASMR.
oh yeah does it want to make you be the father of yourself someone asked and I'm like oh someone's not being watched in the streets
because you're the father and you're the baby and thank you for not wanting to stay at the pleasures homemade
I actually don't know if it worked it just happened we're just going to let it happen ok
I'm so tired so I'm just insane
mommy eating us their birth in us just a circle of life for every plant
I mean like none of it makes sense lore-wise
takeona thank you for becoming a member your profile picture is absolutely horrifying
it's like a smiling peanut
thank you for coming to me bar and the directs for
who's then calling us out in the background that is for decorational purposes
look my 3D horse on the desk I told you I had to do 3D horse
that is for practical effects ok
it's not for any nefarious activities
get in my tummy I've had a nickel for every time
a character with a Scottish accent said that I have 2 nickels in beard
that's so cute
and none of it makes sense lore-wise but it's funny it's very good
literally so you guys I've been in my belly and I've been pregnant with you
you've also been the father and you're also the father of any generation
a feeler like you know like Shibi, Azera, Mercy, ME, AC, you're the father to all of them
cause I was pregnant with them
but Azera is like the goddess of fertility and she's the mother of all of humanity
I give birth to the mother of all of humanity
I made this literally like a feeler development team takes a year to come out with a generation
you guys are like I made this, smile
child support is gonna suck
yeah
you're your own grandma, like a grandma
wait this is for pregnancy I think you're confusing the rules cause no this isn't for
I did have pregnancy roleplays on YouTube right now
but I'm just saying lore implication-wise
the reeflings have done everything and nothing makes sense
yeah we made this
cuttlefish can have 100 to 300 babies in a batch
well unfortunately this cuttlefish can only have 17 max, thank you
okay I put this down
17 babies is more than plenty
yeah I agree
I agree
so I'm just kind of feeling in your ear
just like that all of my subs for pregnant
17 that's all I need to know
look all I'm saying is I don't know
is in October okay
and if I am lucky
then we'll be able to
you know turn the lights off and I'll tell ya
I'm more feeling
17-8 and now
17 girls is more than enough to manage
I'm lucky I'm a part of the team
I also would be 18 girls and I'm like oh I can't even imagine a gen 4
please please please
I'm already struggling to
direct my daughters on the floor
if we are making too more chance with mommy
you are
and I'll tell you exactly when
I need your aid
wait so Mary sees your daughter
yeah and A.C. and Amy and she be in a server all
and might tell me together at the same time
for one year
because the girls were concepted in June last year
and it took an entire year
from the start of concept art
to get all the assets
all the models
all the preparation work
oh what is making that noise
a wire, how dare it
so Amy is your daughter and your little sister
exactly
I think it's needed to sketch the designs
I mean that's true
that's an awfully long chair station
there was five of them
you don't have enough nip nip for the number of babies
I love my daughter's sister
do you have mom Azura and she be in a
so Azura, lord wise, is straight up like the mom of humanity
so I can't really out mom her
she be, I can out mom
easy peasy, lemon squeezy, lord wise
she be hasn't actually pulped out
she hasn't pulped out a wing, you know
but she's called Mel from body type
her sister has a baby
cute, adorable
I love her door and mother way
obviously
yay I get to catch a stream
thank you for joining everyone
I really appreciate it
I know I'm not the most professional
I face more life
especially when I don't
when I don't have a script
but I'm glad I can tinkle your life at all
so yeah
Azura pulped out plainly
she literally pulped out in her first words
where I need gold and I'm like what for
but yeah
your voice is making company
ah ye
you didn't find no give kisses
only if you say please
say please give me kisses mommy
oh like a well-baked ui
cute little replant
kiss
is that better
have I paid the kissing debt
actually I'm not paid the membership kissing debt
I saw someone ask about that
I know I'm not paid the membership kissing debt
kiss
wow
okay
I need to know breathe when I kiss
because of youtube's rules
because of youtube's new rules
I can't breathe when I'm doing kissing ASMR
so I literally have to go
I think
yes for some reason
inner ear breathing
is a valuable event
like a content strike
and I'm already on a warning that doesn't expire
until September
yeah
in particular
like I can still do ear blowing
ah
tada
yes youtube I assume
I spend it to the well of payment processors as always
so
mommy can hold her breath
if I'm doing cute
I had to figure out via trial and error
because thankfully
other ASMR creators
most problems
that they've been having and I saw
another creator
and they did
they were injured in their roleplay
so they grunted
but it was in the ear
and youtube like gave a strike to their video
and I was like ah
okay
I know that my video was removed
because the tape stamp was when I breathed in the ear
and then I saw that
and then it just correlated with everything
and yeah
so I managed to figure out that
you can do kissing
and you can technically do ear licking
but you cannot breathe while you do it
doesn't make sense
I don't understand
but yeah
basically
literally the clapping ASMR was fine
I don't know how
youtube is jealous that they don't give a fuck
so yeah
basically
I made the
ear licking ASMR video
at a later point
with no breathing
just to get to this
that my hypothesis is correct
because I'm 99% sure is
we're returning to puritan times
it's rather fun being a creator
when they don't publicly say there's been an update to T.O.S
go on
go on youtube
tell us what you've done
we already know
but yes
on the 19th of September
my
warning is lifted
so I can repost my content
again to try
with what I wanted to
I have a warning
Emmy has a warning
and a sir has a warning
I don't actually think AC has a warning
so
yeah
it's a very interesting
campaign
thank you to Don and the
Howdy Cuttlefish House of Ocean
and again
you should come down and breathe in the water
I promise it's vain
and that I'm not a sire at all
that has a desire
I forgot why Emmy called
warning
I have no idea
youtube here
I can't stand breathing ASMR
so weak
and Uncle Roger acts it
I feel like I'm going to get exited
but not everyone plays fair
I'm going to tell the girls
they need to ease up
on streaming content
that needs to be removed
as soon as your stream is finished
because we're starting to go on
three months of streaming
and some of the youtube channels
are looking a bit barren
and I'm like
let's ease up on the DMCA
we're going a little bit too far
okay
because that content's looking a wee bit barren
what if I could have spun two days
I don't know if the sponge is too loud
do you guys want to know
a really disgusting fact
repairs
thank you for the super chat
the deep blue has a lot to show me today
but do you remember
when I did
10k
a smart bath celebration stream
when I did
10k
a smart bath celebration stream
when I did
10k
a smart bath celebration stream
I forgot to drain the bath
yeah
I made to get my ASMR tools
and the bath water
was still there
I don't know if the sponge sounds nice
I could wait the sponge a bit
hold on
I'll wait the sponge
I forgot to drain it
it was disgusting
It was showing
how much
no you're not buying my
my marinated
cuttlefish
stock
and you didn't BOW it
Mummy I could just forget
I just
whenever I stream
I get very tired
by the end of it
like
a bit like
rain, rain, not two free flints, you're in the same brain cell, look, they're right next to each other on the comb, ah, ah, ah, ah
okay, does that sponge sound okay, or do you want a different tingle, I don't know, does that sound bad, hold on
I don't know
cause it still shows how long she goes
really, it's like the top, like it has remnants of the oil and then the soap and all of that
see, out of, out of, out of, out of me, I bet you like that, school is an enemy character
do you want to know what really went back, did you just cover the water with this stone this morning cause you didn't touch it
okay, you don't want, you don't have to say it like that
repairs, you are sailing at one way or another
okay, like, don't look on, fang, I'll send you freaking samples of the bathwater
you know TV, like, is this supposed to stop us from licking
I will make an e-girl bathwater tier list, give me some of that stoke, that's actually really funny
could you imagine, feeler, fucking, a stoke of old girls, you can get rabbit boil, you can get um, coke, you can get, you can get polar bear, cuttlefish
and then, I guess little sister stoke, and uh, well, young dairy stoke
mix them all together, mix a heavenly concoction, I don't know what they could have like some sort of psychedelic effect
you can't handle my strongest potion, give yourself some levers, let them know you're useful to them
don't ever say little sisters stoke again
if you mix them all together, you summon the secret seventh member, feeler, real true
you need to be careful, you're gonna summon her in the damn fucking stream, honestly
there should probably be larkin in the shadows right now
we're caught, we're catching coal, we're gonna end this one
that member me
another member confirmed, yeah, the nipple higher
this one he has the biggest member, oh dear, yeah
he's came to say goodnight, rest well, little wreathless
we have about two minutes left
management with the seventh member all along
I cannot handle your strongest path, waver, nectar seller
the secret seventh member is Johnny's time
wait, are you guys trolling, or is it, have I not made it obvious though?
I feel like you guys are trolling me
when I did the gen 2 drawing stream, I only drew five girls
your subscriber here, just wanted to say your works in person, thanks, you're more than welcome
thank you for being in my tummy as I'm braiding with you
the seventh member is actually the voice acting of the girls
I barely survived against the path where you're unbelievably strong
my strongest path water traveler, Shirley the chore
mommy have a tummy, you want kisses to make it better, okay?
I am not offering bread loaves on my donut on, no, we are not doing that
I assure you that much
we get a share that says I survived Johnny's path water for 2024, honestly
honestly mate
we draw but we have high insight scores, that's why we can see you're a kingpin
literally
skullfish stalk would just be a pain to feel
stop, that's actually so funny
that's so cute
okay
I have an old collar that I can put on you
okay, I'm just gonna put it on you now
I'm actually taking out of its wee strappy thing
this isn't my collar, it's not a right j-hope, I was gonna put this collar on you just cause I can
hold still
okay
it's almost on the collar side of this
oh god, I'm stuck like this
why is it so hard to put one stop there then?
I actually can't keep it on
okay, there we go
there you go, okay, keep your long collars
it's like, yeah, it's a cute long collar
we're cute
next, we need the gloves, the milking gloves
these are just regularly latex gloves, okay?
don't, don't
is this shock?
no, I would never put a shock collar on
I cannot tell you how scary that shock stream was
I spoke to Shibi last night
and I was like, girl, you better be careful with that shock collar
cause it is science
and she's like, not anywhere
if you didn't know, Shibi's still in the shock
a collar stream and a heart rate monitor
it's coming up soon to you, I don't know why
because La Ofiya
sorry, this tape is so long to put these gloves on
and Fiya isn't very well at the moment
so she's just doing nothing
wow, please, path over sailor
I'm gonna break it
should I do e-girl sales or path over to you?
ASMR, I will rate that down, cause that's funny
alright, hold on, hold on, rate that down
rate that down, rate that down
e-girl, no, feature, no e-girl
feature where it just
her path over to you
her path over
to you, ASMR
I have so many good ideas
cause I'm milking them from you
it's all good, I'm gonna put
I'm gonna put this on your ears
okay?
the equals to 17 kids, 5 girls in this
there's 6 girls in the next, J, and 6 in the other
every generation will have 6 girls in the alarm
what I'm saying is
there's an apple higher if J2 continues
I'm gonna get it across
shocking thing, yeah
meta is a more milking reason to record
I'm not even sure how to get away with that
I feel proud, I get to make the path more ideal for us one
you're, you're, you're a brain, you're a brain stringer
fun ideas, mainly because I said biotic
I love said biotic
it's such a good concept
and
in this J2 you always talk about, about there are girls
yeah, there's girls
why would there be girls?
nipple higher, which
you call the stream like hi
I'm strong and I
I'm Scottish and I have
5 gen mates
and those gen mates are super awesome
and their links are in the description
and they also do ASMR stuff too, that's true
girls, I want to see men
can you remember it?
cowfish physically picks your brain
that they have a wire
sorry if I'm not talking too much
I'm obviously doing this as
your level of sleepiness
they're decent
we're almost at the 2 month mark
and I get to post my little collage
of all the streams we had this month
I'm a happy being
I think I have to say
I have to say
that I think supermarket simulator
was my favorite game this month
I knew I didn't go back to it
but I could see myself
like rolling on that game
what is this scent?
it literally takes gloves on
and then I have earmuffs
over the microphone
and I'm just rubbing
over the earmuffs
it wasn't felt true
I'm not allowed to play felt true anymore
because the flash stream
didn't do so well
and I need to
like
a few different things
I'm gonna do
thai cam this month
I'm also gonna do a hand cam
like pop and candy
make it
I'm gonna do it on the floor
and I'm gonna leave
excuse me
I'm gonna get some more
oh I can't open it
oh my god sorry I need to take the clothes off
I can't open them more
okay
I need to do a hand cam for both of us
I'm gonna look at
really hard for
a lot
of people to look at
or please remember to hi jaco
I lost the cam
filling up the gloves
there's another grocery store game
that has 4 pairs of gloves
stop
your ears are fantastic
me is me in a band
look forward to future streams
I'm glad
oh that was my throat
I had a throat in my throat
I definitely
plan another hypnosis
video some more stream
but I don't know
what I should do to you
in it
if that makes any sense
maybe
I'll test
to forget your name script
just to try
you know cause that's a bit more
like
heavily suggestive
you know
I can't watch your streams
cause you're live early in the morning
and I work Saturdays don't worry
it's 4 am for me
and it is very very early
but
I'm very excited
to play like a lord of the rings with you
oh my god
you have no idea
but just as a remainder
we flanks the mortal
I come up late 2 hours later
than my usual start day
because because because because
because
the meeting is tomorrow
Chris Underground
thank you for becoming a member
and for direct support
you've never played a Lego game
oh boy
they are like
an actual idol man
honestly
when you put down your water
since the sound quality changed
I bloody hope not
it's a shame
it's on him
quiet man, no thoughts
oh ok
ok
if you're changing our name
you can possibly give us a tour
of the different world or time
we can play with imagery into her
did the mate get unplugged?
ok are you trolling?
ok
I've taken off the ear muffs
are you guys trolling
or did something actually happen?
everything looks correct to me
my OBS disconnected
oh it might be the rim creaking
I just disconnected
on OBS
it sounds good now
I've never trolled this shop
ok you guys are still there
hi
thank you for joining
I know I stream at all great times
bye hi
I'm Johnny
he sent it ok
maybe they didn't realise that
the earmuffs on
I disconnected
I don't know why
it randomly disconnected me
I'm sorry
it's ok we flings
we're still together
this is a perfect opportunity
to introduce yourself and your genies
hi
I'm Johnny
I'm the Scottish Gen
I smell berries
I see snowballs
I have 5 gen mates
if I'm not the flavour for you
your time is perfect for EU
which is a relief because it's hard to find EU
I have to go to work
I'm sorry
memory dietry
loud farbs out
this isn't an Emmy donation stream
oh no he's drawn
he's fine
sorry
people are not thinking of making a reference to Emmy's
I see
I see so excited to come back to you
snowberries
and I'm very excited
with what she's got planned for you
she's done a lot of behind the scenes work
so don't worry snowberries
you eat good very shortly
who cares about work
I'm listening to you
I'll work right now
that's good
that's annoying
but good at this sort of thing
to deal with that voice
I don't know what that means
Johnny is like an intrusive
I talk about ours only to bring
as she's getting appreciate
it's too awesomely
my boyfriend
awesomely that she's so cute
you can come it's too awesomely
it's too awesomely your service mister
I hope I can tickle you
because I'm so cute and funny
tickle tickle tickle all over you
and you're sitting there
and tickling like a good we fled
tickle tickle tickle tickle tickle
whore
whore whore whore
whilla whilla
my little we fled
Even funny, strong, it'd be over for you, Motherfuckers.
You already know it's the most outrageous shit.
It would be awa.
Can we smoke? Look at the seaweed.
Hello, friend.
Good morning, Sonny-chan.
I love you.
We ended the jokes and you were in the sub-star here.
Looking great today. Thanks.
I never do anything different with the both of you.
What happens if I'm in the shadow mode into this?
Oh, that still works. What about this?
Okay.
Oh, that looks weird.
I've not highlighted it for this, but yeah.
Oh, my question mark isn't highlighted.
This is blush.
You can see the W.M.L.F. people.
Thank goodness the microphone is there.
I'm sorry.
I guess the microphone is there.
I didn't see a thing.
Thank you, buddy.
That was literally like a slow-motion anime thing that just happened there.
Mommy, what color?
I actually did Fiboncos, our boxers.
They're black.
There are no panties today.
I have girl boy shorts. They're called boy shorts.
I have black boy shorts on.
They're not there with your name.
They're any flesh-balling type of boxers.
Those boxers are literally made.
Black boxers stand here real good.
I mean, what if I know a top-boy maxing to me?
How much more?
100 years. Thank you for the extended membership.
I love your hypnosis stream. Thank you for all the work you do.
Thank you for being so patient for it as well.
It was a long day in the making.
I think we will be able to do at least one serious hypnosis stream a month.
Once everything comes down, because everything is chaos behind the scenes right now,
everything is on fire. It's okay. I'll make it work.
But I do want to do the forget-your-name one with me.
And then we'll come up with a few hypnosis
role-play for YouTube that we want to do.
Okay.
And we'll take it from there. But thank you very much, Andreas.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Your call, I bet you don't even like real call three.
It's like a screen take and centered call.
I love tinfoil music.
Because you had the dentist appointment.
I hope your little make-up teeth are okay.
You always good. Why should we put pressure on you?
Great. She asked me back to work.
I don't know. Maybe if you make me a pressure cooker, the race will come at faster.
Okay. This is going to start so boring.
But I'm really excited for next week.
Because I've been looking into meal prep.
And I'm going to try and make a free soup for streams.
Because I've been really bad.
And I've been eating takeaway and I feel rubbish.
So I'm going to make a chicken soup.
I've made it before.
But I'm not very good at it.
So I know it's boring, but I'm excited for it.
And I hope it comes out really good.
Because I get to put all my vegetables in it.
Because I've been feeling a bit sick recently.
And my legs, oh my god.
I was walking a magpie home yesterday.
So I went to the shops.
And on the way back, I think I made it to the start.
I fed a magpie some chicken.
And the same magpie visits me every morning.
And did I just hear the wind?
Macaron panel.
And I wasn't at my house yet.
So I had to keep walking.
And the magpie flew down right next to me.
And I'm like, you still have a long way to go.
So I kid you not, I had an imaginary leash with this magpie.
And I was like, okay, come on now.
And it would like follow me.
But then it would stop and look at the books and the grass.
And I'm like, okay, a little bit longer.
And I literally like walked a magpie to my house.
And give it cashew nuts.
It's not gammy.
It's actually a male magpie.
I don't know what to name him.
But he, oh my god, my heat just came on.
Can you hear that?
Sorry, it's really cold in Australia.
It's really cold.
Name him Ray Flay.
I don't know what to name him.
It's been really bad.
He says multiple times.
Yesterday was a fluke.
Plappy.
I'm not plapping them.
What the fuck?
What do you want to use that for?
Disney Princess?
Well, fun fact.
I have never, never been swept by a magpie.
But I have been swept by those fake magpies.
They're black and white.
But they're smaller.
Magnus the magpie.
No, that's not actually going to be a new emote.
The emote is not staying.
It's just a temporary placeholder.
I didn't realize but thanks to the gifted memberships
I actually unlocked a new emote slot.
What about seagulls?
So, seagulls' peaks are so weak
they can't eat the cashew nuts.
But he put leftover food on the grass
and a magpie girl confirmed.
Honestly, I'd entertain it.
Sorry.
Hold on, I need to read this.
For no particular reason at all,
I need to read this too.
Okay, sorry.
Okay, I've read it.
For no particular reason at all.
Okay.
Yes, the magpies have an insane voice box.
I'll do this.
Is it, again, the sense that it makes me really happy?
So, I can understand a magpie's calls.
Like, there's three types of distinct calls.
There's the leave me alone territory call.
They always fight over territory.
Seriously, they're always fight over territory.
And you hear them meow, meow type thing.
Oh, I can call them reef pie.
That's good to hear.
Magpie feeders.
I give them cash.
I don't know why.
I take a lot of satisfaction of feeding birds things
they would never get to naturally taste.
So, like, I feed them leftovers.
I feed them chicken.
I feed them cashew nuts and, like,
all these different types of nuts they never have access to.
But cashew nuts are their favorites.
And I'll fucking listen to this.
So, I bought them solid cashews the first time.
And when I gave them unsolid cashews, they were raging at me.
They were, like, looking up at me like,
hey, what is this?
They were literally raging at me.
That I gave them unsolid cashews.
And I'm like, bro, bro, you're supposed to be healthy.
I'm not only sending you to early grief.
Wait, you're feeding a bird a bird.
Magpies eat chicken.
Now, they eat chicken.
They eat meat.
They don't bite it.
I feed them, like, cheesy chips.
I'd left over cheesy chips from HSB.
Birds don't have the space thingy,
so they actually can't tell.
They actually can't tell if it's got spaces
so I can feed them a little bit of HSB
because I can never finish HSB, so I wonder though.
Yeah.
Wait till you learn what some other fish eat.
Actually, birds only eat grass.
There's so much footage in the UK of seagulls
walking in air creeks,
grabbing a bag of crisps,
pulping it, and then leaving, like, absolute chats.
Oh my god, I just said they're real, sister.
Wow.
It is. I can't believe it.
A bag of wall crisps.
Did you just hear my stomach?
I guess I'm a bit peckish.
Oh, one's got punched in the face by a seagull.
That one is your burger.
Honestly, they're real less.
Oh my god, are those the real reflux?
I'm a big fan.
You're a fan of the reflux.
Goodbye.
Hear that, reflux.
You're popular.
Not just by me.
Strudy's still pregnant.
Okay, birthing is more tempo.
Yeah, I'm waiting for the challenge over the strictest on screen.
Feel enter.
Wow, I can't believe since sister doesn't stream on YouTube,
I wonder if that'll change.
Oh, thank you for the extended membership, Ali Viva.
You sent extra fair ale today.
You sent extra fair ale today, mommy.
Thank you again for the great pregnancy.
You are so lovely, awesome.
Oh, thank you.
Seriously, everyone thought I was going to be a shimp,
but I'm not actually trying hard.
It's so much fun.
Someone literally commented, you know,
for someone called Children Parasite,
you're sure to have a really loving and caring side,
and I'm like, hey.
Imagine I could stream on YouTube.
Imagine Strudy, don't mess with me.
Oh, my God, imagine.
Like, seriously.
Imagine sending a step-by-step instruction
of how your 3D setup works.
Imagine.
Okay, I'm going to say something about since sister
actually did send me a video of her as I help,
and she was like, she fucking spun around her rib
and I saw her give a chair.
And she was like, ignore this way
when I gave her a chair,
because there is like a mark.
And I was like, don't worry,
since I literally have a mark when I give a chair to her.
Both of us are such fucking gamers,
and we were like,
we were like, no, both of us stream naked and stuff.
I was like, oh, don't be embarrassed,
because I streamed both of us naked as well.
Like, my fan nature is on the chain.
We're both just naked and stuff.
Oh, my God.
My way, seriously.
So anyway, I just thought it's very important
that you all know that information, okay?
When we collaborate,
we're both going to be naked and stuff.
On your teeth, open your mouth.
On your teeth and chairs, honestly, though.
What combo did I just walk into?
The most coarse one, okay?
Please, I need to link to the chair.
God, I wish I was a gamer chair.
I really like the chairs.
Tony sponsored by Givenchy.
Are you kidding me?
They would literally drop me so fast if I told them.
Like, I'd be like, oh, yeah, there's so much on this chair,
and I'm going to put my chair itself for now
that you've seen it, to be honest.
I don't know how much I would bet.
You know what?
I'm going to put in my offer, okay?
We're going to start bidding on sister's chair, okay?
I'm going to say a hundred quid.
Speaking of sponsorships, let them be out.
Good, strong, you're 10%.
Oh, give me that.
Name a billion dollars like the final offer.
Use good, strong, you're for 50% of your days.
300% doesn't work.
One day we'll be one collab on Newton and I'll be like,
wait, stop, that's actually a really good idea.
I'm sorry, that is, what the fuck.
Sin, I think we just figured out what game we're going to collab on first
because that's actually hilarious.
And then we'll just, like, straight up just play called
Stop Sin, what the fuck, that's such a good suggestion.
Why didn't you come out with that, Sin?
What the fuck, that's such a good idea.
And then we have to, like, assure, like, nasty camera chairs.
Search and destroy police.
I'm going to be in your police.
We would literally, literally,
actually think Sin would actually win, to be honest.
Can you not do that?
Stop.
Okay, so for those of you who don't know,
back in the college eight days, for some reason,
the terminology was run an arbor train on zombies.
Okay, don't ask.
It's just, it's just the way it is.
Okay, it's just the way it is.
Honestly, I think Sin will win because, um, um,
I just got an idea.
She's an MLG pro, what can I say?
And then we'll start out with a five-kadeon.
Yeah, but us, because I used to fucking camp in corners.
Like, she's having me.
Okay, I used to use a Famous suppressor in the ghost park, okay?
And I had a really high KD, because I did support things like,
I would do the UAV jammer, the UAV, and then a Blackbird,
so all my teammates could help me kill people.
I think it was popularized by high-round players at the time.
Okay.
Yeah.
You level camper, you look, I was really good at winning search
and destroy all I'm saying is, I may or may not have had a hundred
and like 20 win streak or something crazy like that,
like a hundred a billion thingy.
It was just actually so good.
An MLG pro.
Camper.
So yeah, what are you going to do?
I mean, refland now that you know I'm a dirty, dirty, long camper in college.
What are you going to do?
I mean, now that you know that I'm willing to do anything
to win that round for Matty.
We'll call you a bad girl.
We'll make some smores while you get the kills.
360 no scope spec, honestly.
We're sure 360 no scope montage.
Honestly, I wish I had any Black Ops 1v1 member streams.
But I'll do it.
I'll literally destroy all reflands.
And over a fact, I can destroy your college and your Black Ops.
But I can't, I'm worried we may not be able to do it
with Sim.
Sim may actually outdo me.
I'm not good.
The strategy is to be in face clan.
Okay, it's so over.
Okay, you'll destroy everyone in chess.
Oh, yeah.
You guys have no clue.
If he's strong, I remember you.
That's true.
Obtaining face with the Obnak.
Sin and strong versus reflex.
Oh my god, I just saw that for the last time.
Did you do some of the chess version of this?
What do you want to call that?
And when that is over for you, you have actually the idea
of getting a Kota, especially the Black Ops series.
Sorry, but you actually have no coverage.
Like, I used to win every lobby.
Like, I used to be a pub stopper.
It's the Terranology, where you just dominate pubs and games.
And like, if you spend all of it, it'll be different and stuff.
I don't know though.
I just breathed out my ex-mom's controller.
This is my stuff.
It isn't working.
It's got dust in it.
I just breathed in some next level chemicals.
I'm gonna die here.
I think they fixed the Call of Duty server, so I'm not sure.
Literally, I was like eight years old on that game,
screaming to the mic like,
Hi, thank you for joking.
I promise I'm doing ASMR.
Oh my god, we should start our own Call of Duty clan
and call it the Glam clan.
I'm starting the last week here, literally.
I was so excited again.
Do you need a jar of peanut butter or what are you doing with your life?
Obviously, missing the braided jelly.
We can feed that in Cougar.
Is that too loud?
I'm like, try not to do that tonight.
Call it a salty splinter.
We'd call it if we're gonna play what we tell them,
we tell them things together.
There might be an opportunity to play with me at the same time.
The grief links.
Imagine an eight-year-old Scottish girl thread
and your bodily harm also tripling your grief.
Literally, I used to be called like a level boy all the time.
I mean, fuck, I still get it when I gave them a chance at lobbies.
And they're like, what is this? We can do it.
And I'm like, one fuck year into you suck, you go killed by me.
When I played Call of Duty School 100, don't try me until April.
I'll literally beat your record.
120, correct?
Hi, hi.
Hi.
Thank you for telling me.
You can't escape from Darko.
Okay, no, no, no. I'm not that kind of gamer.
Feel it back in, feel it back in.
I'm a level bad gamer, but Black Ops is the only exception.
My record is 126.
Oh, did you lose? Oh, did you die?
Oh, see, I didn't, I never died at KDF5.
I'm not teasing him.
Well, I'm not teasing him, but I did have like a massive KDF5.
Oh my god, sorry, it sucks to suck.
Sorry, you're just not me.
I think that was Black Ops.
Oh, oh, that was an easy game.
Yeah, oh, oh, it is.
I'm teasing, yeah, I'm teasing you.
Now, Black Ops 2 was a hit in all hearts.
It was fun.
And then, the really underrated game mode was Alien and Concourse.
And I'm so sad.
I never got the love it deserved.
It was the perfect progression, that thing.
I'm so sad I didn't die.
Strony's toxic gamers, I can't believe this game.
We need a Strony kind of mode.
So, at least Strony extension.
Oh my god, I wish the ghost servers would come back.
I would set an extended extension, I'm not even kidding.
You plan on making Black Ops 2 at least for the future?
I don't know, I would do it.
Clean, clean, clean your ears gently down the make.
That was my stomach, barely, barely, barely, barely.
I'm getting all the earwax.
If my stomach can stop making noises, I'm running extreme every 2 seconds.
That would be great.
Coming home from school, double HB247, you turn.
Oh my god, stop, you're making me.
Look, the power of Nostalgia.
The power of Nostalgia.
Stonk's like Strony tracking us down because we ruined our KD ratio.
I will make that roleplay right now.
Sticks and stones, I never did the gamble once where you bet your money to win.
I think I did it once in a while, it was like a reason.
Because I was like, oh no, I'm going to lose my bet.
And then ended up winning.
Black Ops ASMR soft warzone since.
It's called Rage ASMR to fall asleep too.
My favorite rifle, you think I use snipers, a Famous.
And then there was the MSMC for Black Ops 2.
And then there was the A911 or something for Black Ops 2 for long range.
Whereas like the Famous was just everything you needed.
ASMR, Stonk's like small child.
It means your KD, your code skills honestly.
I never died once after my brother told me the game.
Unlocking a cold gun to be able to change your contact color and all the emblems.
The emblems are selling also in college right?
You have 1500 hours in code ghost, oh my god.
I love extinction.
I loved like leveling up in it as well.
Because when you put on these things to make it harder,
you go so much of an XP boost that you would like level up to the most basic thing.
Panging on the door.
People in a Kenya in there open this door because you cannot windowson it.
And this is what you deserve for breaking my winstry.
Can we say that's not my load?
Is that a load?
Did they fix the servers on code ghost?
Because if they did, I'm sorry but we're putting up extinction next week.
If they fix the servers, I will play it.
Ironically, we can play extinction together.
I wonder if when Activision realized it could make bank,
if they just made us all focused on zombie.
There was a recent zombie game that came out,
that rifle called, people said it was actually very cute.
Oh no.
Thank you.
Thank you for the extended membership when I played Call of Duty.
My friends called me double, seven zero girls zero.
This is seven turns.
I'm so sorry.
Bless your glowing socks.
Oh, I don't even know why I made that noise.
I'm sorry.
Does it kill your heart?
I'm not sure.
Fire alarm noise.
My glass bubble.
The bubbler.
You're black.
What the fuck?
You can literally hear how pale I am in my voice.
That's bizarre.
That photo campaign is great.
Go ahead, Tokyo.
It's the glass and the blubberer.
Oh my god, not to be a weirdo.
They're like a fangirl or anything.
But Nini literally followed me back.
You know, like one of the biggest ASMRs ever.
Yeah, she like followed me back on Twitter.
So, yeah, you can kind of say I'm a big deal.
I'm not. I'm decent.
But I was like, wait, what?
She actually fucking told me.
Nini.
That Vtuber Nini.
From the Project Production Co.
She literally followed me back on Twitter.
I'm like, oh, hi.
I love you. Please kiss me.
Kiss me.
The way you said the blubberer reminded me of order.
The blubberer, you were both a big deal to me.
Well, okay, I'm going to say something controversial.
I thought, sorry, kissing ASMR, yes.
So I thought that her management would prevent her
from interacting with me.
But I don't know.
Production Co.
I can't be straight now.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm always surprised.
I'm like, are you allowed to interact with us yesterday?
I can get the responsible thing out again.
We are.
I thought that management would be my measure.
Unfortunately, we've had going a few experiences collectively
where people aren't allowed to talk to us
because we had communication stoppers.
And I'm like, ah, okay.
And it's like a shame because obviously it's like public perception
and stuff, and it's very hard to be like, hey, we're normal streamers.
Because you're not going to expect an agency to sit down and watch it
and be like, yeah, we're normal streamers.
And we'll start to sense that that one guy and the change
was responsible, but pulls her tongue out of her stomach.
She exhaled her magma.
So I guess this one's starting.
My heart can only take so many lovely keys.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm going to actually take this squishy toy and tickle it.
Did you get the little ear bands put back on you?
Okay, so it should sound a bit...
The HR will decide your feelings for me.
I'm HR.
I'm a little bit more normal though.
Migration check, darling.
Okay.
I will use self-observe from eating mercy.
I won't, I'll just tell her to spare her back home.
Okay, there we go.
Wow, sorry, my fingers went in the chair.
They're making noises.
You stop that, Mr. Chair.
Record mercy being eaten, please.
Oh, I'll put that in his first don't-a-thon.
Since she wants to do it.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Wow.
Okay.
Chair for him? No.
Careful, if you're too intense, you're going to make a sling.
Please wait until the praise of the chair doubles.
Feel her discard server.
It's linked.
It's notification only.
You can't talk.
It's linked on Twitter.
On the pinned Twitter of the viewer again.
Imagine not liking this.
Or probably some people don't like it.
As in, as in like this stream.
Wink, wink.
Let's not technical back there.
It's decoration, okay?
It's very fully sensed.
Thank you, Chair.
Silk salt comes out.
Imagine.
Real enter.
It's from mine, okay?
Literally, like I sang away my room.
And the person who made my room.
He just stuck that on the wall and I'm like,
you don't want, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll take it, yeah.
I didn't ask for it back, I'll give it.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, yeah, let's go.
I was like, it's an ASMR.
It's a color fish that doesn't lose its color.
It's really nice, actually, when you can work with contractors.
When you can work with commissioners like that,
where you tell them what the deal is
and then they go, wait, how do you even get up there?
I just stand on the table to do it.
I disconnected.
Why didn't what's going on with my connection?
I disconnected twice in the stream.
You'll take it where
I record ASMR on my bed.
Bra, I disconnected again.
I don't know what's going on as twice now.
Don't throw up, you flanks, it's okay.
I'm here.
Don't throw up.
Hypno content is going to be, forget your name next.
There's going to be one monthly scripted hypnosis stream.
I go halfway to throw it up.
You force three seconds, feel our eggs morning,
feel like morning, feel like morning.
I detangle myself and do like four or five times of ASMR to tinkle.
You should consume it for a little while
to make yourself more sensitive to the noise.
We're halfway there in 19K.
Don't say such things.
Don't say such blasphemous things.
Please, I am in so much ASMR today, it's not even funny.
I don't even have the time.
When I finish this stream, I've got a membership watch along
and then I'm going to go back to sleep
and then I'm going to record my Patreon audio for tonight.
And then tomorrow, I need to deal with the clipping program at VLR
and then the day after, I need to do a mock-off
as soon as Donathon and I need to come up with a trailer
for her to record to get edited to advertise her Donathon
and I am perishing.
And then I need to go and edit ASMR
and then I need to write a script for Amy and Mercy
and I can't keep it.
I'll try to reach my own personal goals with content
and I'm just a little bit stressed out.
20K ASMR stream wins.
Maybe by the end of the month, I'm doing one hour offering for ASMR
and then we do a show for ASMR.
You've got to get some employees.
There is going to be a manager earlier today,
but at this point in time,
if we need return on investment,
I don't want to be hiring XYZ when the return on investment
isn't going there, you know what I'm saying?
What could help in getting real and true soon?
Soon, I will have the ability.
But that's not right.
Can you still hear the kisses with the earmuffs?
You could have hired an hour to do it just like that.
Have you been watching the Olympics?
Sadly, I don't have time,
but I hope it's going good for your country.
Good luck to your country at the Olympics.
Coming to a blue twitch near here.
Okay, that was smooth.
Has your country won any medals yet in the Olympics?
Do you need help? It's fine.
I like trying my best everywhere, all at once.
Okay.
I don't even know where my country is going.
Today, I don't want you to be either
maybe at the Olympics.
Are you gambling?
Let's go gambling.
You're doing great.
I really love your ears.
Yeah, did you like being in my U.S.?
Was it fun being in my tummy
and listening to all my little tummy sounds
and my heartbeat?
Yeah.
And then all the cuddly sounds
when we had a nap together at the end.
Or was it the thigh cupping
where I literally squish you with my thighs?
Squish, squish, squish.
Oh, my tummy is sore.
I can't believe it.
I believe I have this thing called hunger.
But don't worry, I'm going to eat in the vibration stream.
I lost all the brain seat.
That's why we don't cap up.
I had to learn the hard way on the outro.
Okay.
Wow, wow, wow.
Another five key and stop.
This is how you lose that freaking height.
It's a drool.
We live in a cardboard box.
I got knives back.
We won another take.
Okay.
I could technically do wooden ASMR
but I'm going to do wooden ASMR.
I'm going to click a little bit.
I can't but worry.
I don't want you to click.
Do you understand me?
Two pieces of wood.
You're not to click.
You're just rotating and stopping.
Okay.
You're picking with these.
I'm dry-harding.
intravenous case would start.
Well, you're getting swallowed.
Is that your heart?
Do you want to hear my heart in a minute?
80% of cap was given.
No, stop.
Stop.
I actually wanted to do a parody ASMR
of girlfriend encourages you.
Like, you're going to...
I can't remember what it was.
It's like a...
basically encouraging you to camp or something.
I can't remember.
I'll remember, sorry.
I don't know.
What do you mean?
Get like four hours or so?
Was it three hours?
I think it was like three hours by the time I fell asleep.
You're like the wooden picks.
These are... these are... okay, so...
I'm quite the resourceful little raccoon, okay?
These are my Chinese and East chopsticks
from our restaurant.
So it's just wooden.
And like you can hear when my skin
brushes against the wood as well.
Okay, you can't look at ASMR at all.
It's like... it doesn't make any sense.
Yeah, like ASMR, it's supposed to be a meme,
but I don't know, sometimes the campus
topic is crazy and stuff.
And I don't want to upset anyone.
I'm just a streamer.
I stream my life away.
Away.
ASMR is trying to slushy.
I mean, that's where the four words are going to be called.
And...
You've seen that color version real life, have you?
Was that cute?
I'm so sorry, my hand kicks on.
It's very cold, it's very cold
and I don't want my cats to be cold.
Because I love my baby.
He's my little friend.
I love my babies.
My little furry babies.
Hello, thank you for hanging on stream.
I'm just...
I'm currently picking away at your ears right now,
actually just making sure they're nice and clean,
but maybe careful that I don't touch the inside
microphone part because if I do, then it's all over.
Call incoming.
It's time to hang.
Also, if I'm using a wasteful of child support,
probably you spawn that thing.
Wrap your willy-meat.
If you spawn that, you won't be fruit.
Chopsticks, it sounds like an enemy.
This time, I was reading in Karnia,
and it does a Chinese thing on it, like...
I wonder if I can take your...
Can I trim on your ears?
I have no idea what that sounds like.
Absolute rhythm.
It looks like I've got a lot of chopsticks on your ears.
You got mud on your face.
You make this grease.
You mean...
Yeah, I'm gonna piano your ears.
I'm pianoing your ears.
This is the fastest thing that goes on the list.
Mommy, does the pongo cat mean one of your ears?
Oh my god, I should commission someone as...
It's like my butt, but you're just refling
to the pongo cat, my butt.
Any artist that can do that, hello?
Any artist that can do that, please?
I beg.
Yeah.
The microphone is really...
Because I'm a...
I mean, green.
Well, not really.
Because I've got big fat arms.
But I love my mood.
Some people get really fast triggers
ASMR, but I just don't always pay them.
I don't like making fast ASMR
because if someone's all open to ears
and they're like...
It's just annoying.
I'm about crazy.
Maybe it's just a preference.
Okay, I'm brushing your ear a little bit.
Speedrun ASMR, like, yeah,
like this fast ASMR speaker and stuff.
And they're like...
It's good, it's good, it's good, it's good.
Like, I can't say it like this.
And ASMR is like...
I'm like...
I'm not supposed to take off.
I'm literally just getting fairly slow.
But I feel so fine.
Can't beat this.
I can't even bring up length, so I'm actually raging
and watching back the stream.
And to see if I was just being really bad at the game.
And I'm like, no, that game's impossible.
Sorry about that.
Thanks a lot.
ASMR's were just sleep fasts for a bit now.
Yeah.
I'm good with that.
Let's go gambling.
Oh, dang it.
Beat you with a fried bun is more true.
Yeah, but does the average reach you
or do you break them with your ASMR?
When you're the father?
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about.
There's a first time for everything, okay?
Fast ASMR only works with some deep oily ear massages.
I haven't, not with them.
Can be blinks, but as a 5k deal,
you can't look, okay,
if you're to some latches on the server.
I'm sorry, but I'm actually going to start going on a round
about blinks.
I don't know who they think they are,
but why on earth did I accidentally
stumble upon the fucking dark souls
of Expo's original games?
Because who freakin' made that game?
I'm sorry.
I didn't ask you to hit me.
He saves the princess and all that.
Oh my god, you're playing hell divers.
Oh my god, they're all close to the left.
They're diving down.
They're going to get you.
Throw your name.
Go, go, call it.
Call in your logo today.
It's up down left, left right up.
Okay, go, go, call in your name.
I'm sorry.
Girlfriend is here in your car, aren't you?
If only we didn't get your kiss in the blink of an eye.
I know, it's actually so annoying.
I just, I don't know why YouTube doesn't know
why anyone's bizarre.
It's like, I don't know why they don't know about it,
but I know we're just playing by force.
Just go with Twitch.
Ah yes, let me up my fan base.
I've accumulated from two months of consistency
straight into Twitch.
I apologize, but I can't do that
because none of what you're saying
is very acceptable to me.
I'm sorry.
None of what you're saying is very acceptable
by Twitch's standards, so...
Yeah, I'm, I'm a big YouTuber.
Exactly.
Yes, like, keep looking.
Blinks versus Rogues.
Literally none of our designs are acceptable
on Twitch, say...
Yeah.
And no, I'm not redesigning.
Well, if Blinks was actually
made by the same devs or so.
Honestly, I believe it.
I honestly wouldn't believe it.
If a director for the Dark Souls
was actually secretly on Blinks...
Thank you for the good chat.
I wish I had a banner on YouTube.
Has been gone already, though.
And it's a little glitchy, so...
I must say, it's better for YouTube
because, at least, she has no personality
after all this.
And these are, you know, unfortunately
operating dead, dead, dead.
What?
Oh, it's not because of the video.
Yay, it's the banner on the IFC.
I mean, fucking Fallen Shadows.
Literally, a perfect example.
She had it on her list recently, as well,
for being a...
for visual content.
And I'm like...
No question mark.
Fallen Shadow isn't like that.
You went from chilling.
Yeah.
Cool.
Yee.
Shh, shh, shh, shh.
Twitch is terrible for visual
versus literally, like, one for a bitch.
You want to be slainly different.
Is that as well?
I
I brush, I brush your ears
to get them all nice and clean.
Clean, clean, clean your ears
of all the dust and debris.
Tickle, tickle, tickle, tickle, tickle.
Life is like a dream.
Wow.
Well, streaming sites have a hardcore
when you're not doing these features.
And features, as far as the views are concerned,
support you to the end of the scoop.
And yeah, if you're really killing it,
everything is going to survive.
And it's like, well, obviously we're not going to
walk out for me, Wax, you know.
I'm not going to get lonely for you.
I
I'm quite fine.
Yes, the one good thing about YouTube as well
is I can dictate the ads in the stream
and I don't put any ads on streams at all.
Like, YouTube prompts me
every single time YouTube's like
do you want to play an ad, do you want to play an ad?
And I'm like, nope, nope, nope, nope, stop asking.
But on Twitch it's forced.
But at least on YouTube,
I can stream up to an ASMR stream
and it doesn't get interrupted with ads.
It's just a shame that YouTube
implemented quite a while back now.
But they force ads on the end of YouTube
videos before they did it.
Like, you could have an ad at the start
and nothing else.
But they completely took
the ability away
and now they force an ad
at the start and the end.
The only thing I can control
when I upload an ASMR roleplay
is if there's mid role ads
in the middle of the video.
And I take off by default.
Like, I take off because I don't want to wake you up.
Because, you know, they're playing
an astronomically loud ad.
Like, you know, even if
they were smart about it
and did, like, volume control
and did really quiet ads
then, you know, maybe some ASMRs
would go for the option.
But because they insist
on layeringly loud ads,
it's absolutely ridiculous.
Twitch ads are forced and
embedded YouTube is thrown into the...
I think so.
I will change in the future.
Unfortunately,
so let's enjoy this
livestream
for what it's worth.
Because
I don't think we'll always get this
bass boosted
on to the sound. What does it feel like?
It feels like
like
I do some little ear tappies
with my hands.
YouTube will see how much
the numbers can go up in game creation.
Literally, it's just
infinite growth and
nothing else.
And I don't get involved. I want to see
what content creators eat.
You know, I'm a content creator too.
It would be hypocritical.
All I'm saying is that
it's not necessary to have ads
literally everywhere that
interrupt the viewing experience.
Hello. Thank you for joining me.
I'm Strani.
Hi.
I mean, break-ins I guess.
Yes, it's literally
creating the problem
solution.
I can
set defaults
so every stream
I tell YouTube to prompt me
to create an ad because I can
dictate where it goes.
But there's an option for
auto ads and it says for the
best viewing experience.
And it's like, no, it's not.
It's literally going to make people
click off of streams.
Like, don't be so silly.
The best viewing experience
can have in here, honestly.
I want to interact here.
Literally, me with a fucking break-in
sample right now.
I'm obsessed with all the life in.
You are going to love
Fauna then.
She does ASMR and she's awesome.
So don't be scared.
And I think she's getting close to
a million subscribers only.
She's already hit a million.
Oh my god, she's going to get a play button
for a million subscribers.
Hello, hi, hi.
Fauna sent me some ASMR in a minute
but she does have a fantastic library
of live streams
and videos.
And some of them are like, ever slow
well.
It's very busy, busy.
Very busy, busy to be on the library.
If you do forces ads,
just ask them for the ad bloggers.
True unparthing ASMR
is where I saw
a book.
I love you.
Love you too, love you.
Fauna bloggers.
I was trying to fauna collab
with this school.
She has a adorable
absolutely perfect accent
and then I'm in the age
who said go and launch.
Yeah, I don't think that's gonna happen.
Even as a day is more
fauna as a comfy babe, yeah.
I can't believe I missed
my own children being bored.
Yeah, and yourself as well.
I can't believe that
you didn't watch the video
of
of the
Berry Kidsy roleplay on my
YouTube channel.
Phil's call halfway through the club
I'm wanting to do Phil's call as ASMR.
I think I'm gonna do that nurse
lace person.
Both of my parents are double part.
How do you miss your friend?
I think feel her and be sure to
we'd be big.
I think
we would have to be a bit bigger
to get anyone's attention
at that level.
I'm gonna be honest.
I can't work it
slightly harder
than I first imagined.
I'll say that, literally I've been very
like everyone's been so nice that I've reached out to
so maybe I just don't need
to be such a
sorry, I didn't mean to pop.
Sorry.
So
don't do birth ASMR.
No, I'm not gonna maybe do that.
I'm not gonna do birth.
Don't worry.
I don't even know
how you make that like
you miss the baby making ASMR.
He's gonna act as a nice face
for us to
follow the first Pokemon trainer,
scrawny Scotland.
Literally the entire
collab between me and Fauna has just been
like member that thing with the English folks
right there, eradicating the Scots.
What do you think about that?
Go on, go on.
I think both ASMR is just screaming.
Literally, I'm like why would anyone want that?
Yeah.
Cheese.
I'll do
I'll do eating you next.
I don't mind eating you.
Oh, dammel man.
Okay, I don't know who dammel man is.
I don't know.
Well, I'm gonna be honest.
I'm slightly collabed in the web
so personally, I don't know about the other girls
but I am
an over my head at this point in time.
And I can admit it.
I can admit it.
This is happening in the reef,
like up above that.
What?
So you're just never gonna birth this?
Are you stuck inside your family?
Yeah, you can become a rock, baby.
A stone.
You're gonna get calcified in my whip
and removed, like a choumah.
A nature themed one.
Oh yeah, easy piece.
You could write that.
I say facts about the ocean
and the water and all the sea creatures
and she does it by land creatures
and the plants and stuff.
Ever since watching how to train your dragon
as a kid I've fallen in love with Scottish accents.
Oh, hi.
One giant kidney star.
We're gonna be coming here tonight.
The
Servant Deer.
Pretty much.
Okay.
Does anyone know
if Shabee's coming online
or did she have to cancel
because we feel
a lot of accents
are in New York City.
What are you talking about?
Joke.
It's me.
Holly Quinzel.
Oh, I love being
in New York for some
hot dogs.
She's
planning her 10k
in 10 minutes.
Okay.
New York
gen count.
Stop. What do you mean stop
at Mr. J?
I just love talking to my real old
ending New York act.
I am so sorry.
Absolutely terrible.
Not 10 minutes, 2 hours.
I'll just read her.
Finally, your real voice comes out.
Exactly.
Oh, sorry. Exactly.
I love
the way
people in New York
um, I don't know
where are we going
to block the co-op
Mr. J.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you
for the 10k
in 10 minutes.
I'm so glad
that you
enjoy
my ASMR
in New York
to do.
By the way, your models
are cute as well.
Thank you.
In a while, yeah,
do you think it's cute
and bouncy
and my hair flows
and my titties
and the best part
is
my
hair.
Ta-da.
I start
at once.
But not right now.
It's not going to be long until Mommy reaches 20k.
Wow, I need to start firing up
my ASMRs.
Can we get J.C.
Calibre with your ash?
Ash is a little toward.
You better be.
Wait, I need to.
Ash? Ash is a little toward?
What the fuck?
I can't do it.
I can't seem to whisper.
I can't seem to whisper, bro.
Sorry, I can't do it.
I am okay.
The darker model
with the glowing contrast.
Yeah.
Wow.
Wow, wow, wow.
Can you change the speed of the head?
No, but I am
going to ask for it.
I am going to get
slow, medium, and fast hypnosis
for my hair.
Man, your voice is
so nice.
I can see.
I can't read that one out loud.
Help me.
She won't know.
Strawberry, yes, I am a cowlfish.
I do hypnosis.
But I normally do a bit more
than just visual, okay?
But yeah, cowlfish use hypnosis
for hunting and defense techniques.
I should just remember several of them.
Can we get some close breathing?
Unfortunately, no,
because YouTube eats us.
You can get far away breathing.
I don't think I can reach that.
I guess ASMR.
How do you?
Oh, I need to take your collar off
before the end of the stream.
Hold on.
Let me take it off.
I don't want you to forget that you've got
an important side with it.
Okay, I'm going to get your collars off.
I have a distant breathing,
but I don't have a tube.
Who has a tube on standby?
Put the short collar on nice.
Shiny to membership streams.
Stay up, yep.
We're watching beauty and the beast.
Or I should do a pet play ball
where you're the pet.
He's a good boy.
Do you need a chain?
Give me your ball, little reflin ball.
He's a good boy.
It's you.
You're a good boy.
Repairs.
Thank you for the super chat.
Brothers in Australia went up over
my friends, but I need to know
if I should reply because I want 600.
I would keep the money.
Park Park, I want to pay people.
Oh no, you're going to get moss off.
You be mean.
We can't change chin rubs if we pay.
Oh, you get more than just chin rubs.
I'm going to show you that one.
Wow.
All in her nuts.
Take the money.
Okay, I will work on a pet play stream
for the next public ASMR stream.
Pay the house while you're at it.
This is about your way.
90% of cameras stop.
Chat is frightened.
Chat is called the reflinx in this neighborhood.
I don't really say chin.
Any ticklers
need a firehawk.
I know you.
Hold on, let me check
that everything
everything's cool
when you're part of the team.
But yeah, I would definitely
be open to a stream
where
we do pet play.
Sorry, I said I don't care if it makes me weird.
I don't care if it makes me weird.
I'm doing it. You can't stop me.
You had more army.
Hold on.
Okay, I'm going to eat.
Of all the wise words I was trying to
say,
literally take your air nicks
and play it safe with them.
Do you think the reflinx
would be a snow bearer in a war?
What?
Why are you fighting?
There's all rings as in army.
Actually, you know what? That was my fault.
My bad. My bad. That's it. The terminology of army.
No, you're not going to be fighting anyone.
The only thing you need to fight
is that you also have to purchase more ink, okay?
We don't, we lose
to those guys.
No, while in war, any
fight in war, we win
automatically against everyone.
But we would have to lure them
into the water.
Okay.
If they don't get the signal, sir.
We'll enter.
We're going to war? No, I'm not sending you a war.
Then draw. I'm just trying every group
except the retina.
The world's strongest navy, truly.
Fight in reefing, on reefing
violence, as someone mentioned.
A space otterskin.
I can take my egg for war
even. Test of strong backs
and we all
engage hypnosis to lure them.
As far as a giant test
that would be in our army,
it's not like she can swim to the bottom of the ocean
with us. We're safe in the water.
I have bone spurs.
Sorry, I'm all confused.
Mommy, aren't reefing abuse real?
Okay, I let the reef links.
I am going to redirect
into Shibi.
And for those of you who are
members, I know Shibi comes on
in two hours.
Those of you who are members, I am
going to get some food and then we're
going to watch a beauty and the beast together.
Because I'm a little
married and I love beauty and the beast.
And I hope you
have downloaded the old beauty
and the beast, not the one
with Emma and the
coffee one, okay?
Could we win against a polar bear?
I don't know. I feel like it's kind of like
land versus sea. We're good on the war
but we're not good on the land.
Thank you so so much for
hanging.
And then
I'm going to redirect
into Shibi.
I know she's two hours away.
Don't worry about it.
She's doing a very fun heart rate
show called her stream so do look
out for that. I'm going to go get
some food and then I'm going to pump back up
in five minutes. Okay, love reefing.
Thank you so so much
for hanging.
And I'll see you tomorrow
for some lake lord in the ranks.
Then I do star stream to members later
if you're not normal with that.
I'll make up with an insurance of lake lord
in the ranks, okay?
Thank you darling.
If you're not subscribed
don't be shy to subscribe and like
and you
just go strutting for 10% off
of your cameras I'm sorry.
But I do ASMR streams
every week and role plays too.
I recently uploaded
pregnancy.
Okay, goodbye little reefing.
Love you.
I'll see you for the next ASMR stream
where I treat you like a dog.
I said what I said
and I will stand on that.
Bye.